yesterday I entered abortion rally
outside the Supreme Court Chuck Schumer
the master of heartfelt Senate hypocrisy
said this I want to tell you about such
I want to tell you Kavanagh you have
released the whirlwind and you out rages
stuff even Chief Justice John Roberts
called chucks comments dangerous sensing
trouble Schumer's office offered a
cowards lie claiming Chuck really meant
Republicans would pay not the judges by
birthing a major reproductive rights
movement which we know is false because
that movement already exists I want to
tell you a senator gasbag never before
in the history has the unborn ever faced
such eight because you know they're just
a bag of cells unlucky enough to be
conceived after these lucky women were
born abortions are one of the safest
procedures you could do an evaluation
faces safer than traction today we are
taking the opportunity to present
reproductive freedom including abortion
for exactly what it is no less than
Liberty itself to where my people who
had abortions
we'll never stop talking about my
abortion thank you for that so what is
Chuck Schumer really he's not a
firebrand or a bomb thrower he's just a
follower following them the abortion
movement has moved from the valley of
abortion being legal and rare to come
one come all
it's a descent into the irrational where
one denies science as a way to deny
limits to their demands and in this move
where abortion is no longer a tragic
decision but a choice to be championed
laughed about even bragged about it's
understandable that a weak and anxious
man like Chuck would find himself swept
up in the hawkish fever for casual
termination of the small and
inconvenient funny how some in the media
worried that the judges were being
threatened know Chuck's just another
empty grandstanding joke the judges can
take care of themselves pity those who
never have that chance so judge I did a
half apology I think we have it here I'd
love to you to comment after we play it
okay let's do it
okay yeah I said open I'm from Brooklyn
we speak in strong language I shouldn't
have used the words I did but in no way
was I making a threat I never never
would do such a thing so now he's from
Brooklyn he's using that excuse judge I
never never would do such a thing look
he here is what happened he said Gorsuch
Kavanagh you will pay the price you
won't know what hit you yeah okay he was
not talking about anything but those
justices he was intimidating them he was
threatening them he was calling a mob to
incite calling on a mob exciting as far
as I'm concerned violence okay that is a
call to action in real time while the
Supreme Court that they're just outside
of is hearing the very case that this
group is concerned about it's the first
abortion case since these two new judges
have taken their seats on the Supreme
Court so when the Chief Justice of the
Supreme Court comes out and says that it
is a dangerous threat you can rest
assure that it is a threat and there
what are they going to do these judges
have a lifetime appointment so it's not
like
can get them out of office it's not like
that they can you know call them or have
someone run against them it's basically
politicizing the Supreme Court and it's
basically threatening them and there are
those who were calling upon Chuck
Schumer to be number one prosecuted
number two calling upon him to resign
number three calling upon him to step
down from his position as minority
leader as well as making sure that
someone am impeached which I think would
be such poetic justice but this is the
same guy who said you mess with the
Intel community and now mess with you
six ways to Sunday and look at what
happened to Donald Trump yeah look at
what happened to America for two years
he's at it again there's a wad I my
feeling is that he was playing to the
crowd but pro-choice people and I know a
lot of them and I think you're
pro-choice I think have to contemplate
the intensity of that fetal hate that
you sing just like like bubbling out of
that group Isis and he got suckered into
that I don't think that's true first of
all during the death of unborn children
her profile look as you said on prota I
wouldn't there I'm such a lover of
children and family I just don't think
that's about though no because you say
and also abortion is that I think a
record low rate in the country right now
but I do think what strikes me is to
come to your point judge that we see the
Chief Justice respond and I was taken by
this and I think that obviously Charles
Chuck Schumer and Mitch McConnell and
others were taken the Chief Justice said
that was a dangerous comment right but
then I thought to myself well what the
Chief Justice didn't say anything when
the president was going after Sotomayor
was going after Ruth right he didn't say
anything when the president said oh that
that Mexican he can't a Mexican can't be
a judge it strikes me that what we see
is the president has said and brags
about the number of conservatives he has
put on the court he brags about having
though he shows up at a major
anti-abortion rally when other
Republican president it doesn't mean a
thing well here's a diff he's political
didn't go to these judges office in
front of a huge angry crowd and make a
veil of the Supreme Court won an angry
screaming crowd Jessica left March was a
loving large pro-life person acting like
that one oh yeah the pro-lifers the only
thing you could do into a pro-lifer is
set up Nicolas Sandman that's all you
can do Dana I want to ask you what
bothers me is like I'm I'm pro-life I
understand that abortion is here and
there's nothing you're gonna be able to
do about it
but when you see that you realize it's
moved away from reproductive rights to a
kind of a fetal fascism it's like you if
you are not part of their battle or
their war on there that side of the war
you're as bet you're as good as dead it
was really interesting to that well for
Chief Justice Roberts has always said
ever since his confirmation hearings in
2005 he believes in precedent he doesn't
see like when these abortion cases are
coming their way I think that he is
reluctant to be guiding this one what's
gonna overturn roe v wade they might do
it eventually I don't know this this
this case out of Louisiana's is one of
them but the other thing about this is
just the other night we had Super
Tuesday and we got the Fox News voter
analysis from each state and if you
looked at the issues of what are the
most important issues to you this is
Democrats yeah and it was health care
and it was jobs and then climate and
then the like like 1 percent in almost
every single state said abortion was
that their mo an issue so Chuck Schumer
like from a political standpoint it
doesn't have to go and face this angry
crap right he doesn't have to go and be
a part of it but he chose to and then he
got caught up in it and it's like
stepping on a rake yeah in the Senate
floor
I think abortion though is obviously
polarizing issue but the Supreme Court
which is a real token for the President
to say you know what I put two
conservative judges on the court is
going to be a big issue in November now
for Democrats and I think this is a
signals to how important it's gonna be
Benny that's it sure okay